he took
monday edition
p-f-t-o-t chris sims mike florio stuff
we didn't get to or didn't get to talk
about as much as we would like to on
today's pft live chris let's get right
to it four arrests happened on saturday
now two of them were for incidents that
occurred earlier in the week that
bizarre
allegation of a party that went south
when
quentin dunbar the seahawks defensive
back and deandre baker the giants
defensive back allegedly brandished
weapons and
stole money and jewelry and after a
couple of days of being
on the loose without turning themselves
in they did on saturday they were
released on bail on sunday they both
faced serious charges of armed robbery
for both of them and uh aggravated
assault with a firearm for baker um and
then on top of that cody latimer the
washington receiver was arrested that uh
it was an incident that began with shots
being fired uh shortly after midnight
latimer was booked on charge of assault
in the second degree menacing illegal
discharge of a firearm and prohibited
use of a weapon and reckless
endangerment and then at oliver the
bill's defensive tackle top 10 pick in
2019 arrested on charges of dwi and
unlawful possession of a weapon chris
look i'm not used to
in recent years this kind of a rash of
incidents the nfl had done a great job
and the players have done a great job of
getting these off-field incidents under
control and between the 2007
beefing up of the personal conduct
policy after the pacman jones and chris
henry incidents and then again in 2014
after ray rice when the nfl took it to
an even higher level we have seen guys
avoid trouble far more often than not
and even 4 out of 2 80 roster spots is
statistically very small the fact that
players had been staying out of trouble
makes this kind of thing
more noticeable when it happens so in a
way in a way the fact that we're focused
on this and that this is unusual it's a
testament to how well players have been
behaving that that we're not numb to
this that when it happens we get oh what
in the world is going on well the
players have been staying out of trouble
so it's more significant when there is a
rash like this that happens out of the
blue
yeah really i mean uh it is amazing you
know the nfl has done a great job the
players the nfl pa the nfl itself you
know yeah the message has gotten out
there players have been smart for the
most case you know and i'm really you
know with 2 000 plus players
and if you looked at the history or the
background of a lot of these players and
where they came from honestly i'm
surprised it happens as little as it
does and with this case i mean i think
what's shocking is it's just that you
know all four of four players hit us
just like bam bam bam all of a sudden on
a friday and a saturday and all of a
sudden we're like man what the hell is
going on here the first thing i thought
of mike too you know is i doubt we have
four arrests on saturday or anything
like that if we had players back in the
facilities and otas and off-season
training it happened now you know you
might have had one of these
the world's not perfect i understand
that but i think what you're seeing is
players with a lot of free time on their
hands these are young kids with money in
their pockets a lot of the times you
know life is crazy at that age a little
bit too and of course you think you're
invincible plus you don't have the
support system of your team and players
around you you know there is something
to that when you get there in march okay
my free time's over okay i got a coach
yelling at me every day telling me don't
be that guy don't get in trouble don't
put our organization in a tough spot let
alone you have teammates around you to
where when you might think about oh i
want to go do something stupid or
whatever uh i'll just go to my teammates
house and we'll have a barbecue and hang
out there and i'll be safe and that's a
big aspect of i think players lives
that's missing right now and i think
that's probably a big reason you saw
this you know little issues these issues
this last week
you're absolutely right it's that
structure that comes from the off-season
program the ability to have messages
constantly reinforced by the coach and
and and the assistance that comes from
other members of the staff if there is a
player that they're concerned about that
these teams have a vested interest in
keeping guys out of trouble and
they like it when they have the players
in the building because they feel more
confident they can help the players make
good decisions and also you're keeping
them occupied you're keeping them busy
and yeah instead of going out getting
into trouble they're playing video games
with a teammate going to a teammate's
house right for dinner spending time
together as part of this common effort
to get ready for training camp and it's
always that break between the end of the
off season program and the start of
training camp where coaches and general
managers have the greatest concern they
finally get away from everything and
they're sleeping with one eye open
because they're worried about what's
going to happen but in recent years
guys have found a way to stay out of
trouble again there was a time when it
seemed like every night or every weekend
in memorial day weekend it was clockwork
there would be multiple arrests coming
out of that typically something
happening in south beach where you know
a guy did something he shouldn't have
done he got in a spot he shouldn't have
been in but between the enhanced
penalties that the nfl imposes on
players now and this this this ongoing
effort by teams to get through to the
players and reinforce that message
you take that away this year
and and i think what it does
it it reminds the league and it reminds
the teams right now that they better
incorporate something meaningful into
these zoom sessions into these efforts
to communicate with the players you know
they're worried about getting their
offenses and defenses in yeah ready for
the season with all this stuff it may be
that for some of these teams those
things that would be constantly there
those constant reminders those programs
those efforts maybe they've been
neglected by some teams and even then
it's it's not nearly as effective as it
is when you're face to face but i i
guarantee you this week
most if not all teams are going to be
taking a look at to what they need to be
saying and doing through these remote
sessions to get guys to be more careful
i agree i mean you're right you know
mike i didn't even think about that but
like usually during this time of the
year you have player development
meetings especially for the young
players the first the second the third
the fourth year players where you know
the leader of that
department in your organization has
little meetings hey wednesday at you
know 12 30 everybody's got to be in the
team meeting room if you're four years
or under in the nfl and they're going to
hit a life topic on that day whether
that's taking care of your checkbook or
how to manage your money or whatever it
may be and you're right mike i mean i
haven't really thought about that that's
missing right now and that is another
you know
talking point or something again that's
going to get players to reconsider or
just do things the right way get them
going down the right path let alone i
think the biggest thing is not having
your teammates you know again especially
for young guys
i just know with me
you know a guy like me and dwight smith
we might have gone off and had a lot of
fun and been stupid and got in trouble
but thank god rondae barber was having a
barbecue and we went there and we could
hang out there and drink beers and have
fun whatever it may be
and i think those are where that's when
you talk about oh this guy you know we
hear veteran players he's good for a
locker room or he does this and does
that he's good for the culture you know
that's where a really good veteran
player comes in when you go oh this guy
okay he's a little rough around the
edges he's got you know some issues
maybe i could take him under my wing and
show him the right way the right path
and to me that was always the the most
important support system i ever saw in
my career in the nfl
this incident with deandre baker and
quentin dunbar is very bizarre it sounds
like a bad episode sopranos if the
allegations are true now here's where it
stands
the lawyers profess the innocence of
their clients which look i think that
there's an unbeaten streak of lawyers
saying their clients are innocent all
the way back to the
the establishment of the criminal
justice system
but both lawyers claim they have
evidence they have affidavits that
contradict the witness statements and
look i
i i
i want to see
the original police statements i want to
see these affidavits before i come to
any conclusions
but you know there's a chance that
that these affidavits to the extent they
contradict the information that was
harvested on the evening of the incident
that could create enough reasonable
doubt that prevents quentin dunbar and
deandre baker from ever being convicted
the other side of it though chris is
if it looks like
it's
you know too convenient if it looks like
maybe
after the dust settled there was an
effort to basically get witnesses to
recant and change their tune and not
snitch on these guys that that may be
obvious as well
from the content of the statements i
want to see how they conflict i want to
see
how dramatic the change is and then i'm
going to want to see what these
witnesses would have to say when they
have to reconcile the two statements
because ultimately a jury is going to be
looking at this saying wait a minute
wait it actually could make it easier
for the prosecution to prove their case
if it's so over the top and conflicts so
dramatically with what was said on the
evening in question that's why they get
these statements they get them fresh
before they can be corrupted by anything
the passage of time a faulty memory or
somebody who decides to come around with
a little something something to get them
to say something other than what they
already said i'm not saying that's what
happened here but these are the things
you have to take into account that's why
you get the statement fresh and there's
no statement more reliable than the
statement obtained at the scene so
there's a lot to flesh out here it's by
no means a get out of jail free card
literally for quentin dunbar and deandre
baker it complicates the case the
lawyers think that it should end the
case right now which is what they're
paid to say
uh this thing is going to be
i think complicated it's going to take
some time and it's not going to be cheap
for either player
no i i can't imagine it to be in cheap
no let alone i mean
gosh it's going to really put them in
the doghouse with their organizations
regardless i mean they were in the in a
bad spot these are things that you know
teams preach don't put yourselves or
don't be in positions to where you know
you could be accused of this whether
they're guilty or not like you know like
you said we don't know yet but to me the
other thing that's interesting here mike
and you know with the amount of money
we're talking about and it sounds like
he i don't know exactly where this went
down but the watches and everything i
mean i i would think there's got to be a
camera somewhere i mean or a phone
somebody got somebody on camera here you
know to to me to where would be able to
prove something
and i'm also just and again i know right
now this is all early and i'm not trying
to say mr baker or mr dunbar or guilty
or anything but to me i'm just
fascinated if it did go down to go want
to be like this the psychology of it to
go
wait did you guys really think you're
going to get away with this like that
that's to me where i'm almost like
they couldn't have done this because did
they really think as nfl starting
corners in football they would be able
to do this and get away with it so
that's where i'm like mind blown emoji
right now about this topic but we'll see
where it goes
well it's a combination of youth
stupidity alcohol
maybe something stronger alcohol you
know there's a lot of hey uh the the the
prisons throughout this country are not
filled with geniuses and uh you know of
course there are a lot of other reasons
why guys get in trouble and there are
issues with the criminal justice system
and uh we don't nearly have enough time
to even begin to address those but yeah
stupidity i think has contributed to a
lot of people ending up behind bars um
one other thing about deandre baker he's
been told by the giants just go ahead
and stay away from these zoom meetings
focus on your legal issues for now
uh which is probably a smart thing to do
and i think both guys are going to be
looking at placement on the commissioner
exempt list
if these charges aren't resolved when
the time comes for teams to get together
again the charges are too serious i
think for the league not to use the
commissioner exempt list so we'll keep
everyone updated on how these cases
unfold before we go one other thing that
that popped up last week chris you
haven't had a chance to chime in on it
in this setting or in pft live we didn't
talk about it during the show today and
on friday it was big cat the james
harrison admission from the bar stool
sports going deep podcast with willie
colon and steven shea that
that when
james harrison was fined seventy five
thousand dollars in 2010 for an illegal
hit on brown's receiver mohamed massaqua
mike tomlin the coach of the steelers
gave harrison an envelope art rooney ii
the steelers president has denied the
harrison allegations i don't know why
mike tomlin hasn't said anything about
it james harrison went to instagram on
friday and he essentially confirmed that
he did get an envelope he just lashed
out at the idea that
the giving of an envelope to james
harrison after he was fined by the
league is similar to a bounty
uh that's his beef with it he has not
recanted even though his agent has tried
to put the toothpaste back in the tube
harrison is not recanted tomlin hasn't
said anything it's clearly a violation
of the rules to pay someone's fine
uh and i agree it's not a bounty per se
there are issues with this though and
there are problems with paying a
player's fine it
it takes away the disincentive to get
fined if you know that that your your
your coach is going to give you the
money back and we don't know how much
money mike tomlin gave james harris and
chris but uh you know look it's it's
something that if it happened in the
past year or two i think the nfl would
be all over it the fact that it happened
10 years ago the nfl is going to hope
that it dies down and that they can move
on and they can turn the page and it
quickly becomes forgotten because they
don't want to go back 10 years and deal
with something that happened that is
over that is done that happened before
the bounty scandal which kind of reset
everyone's clock to zero on what is and
isn't permitted when it comes to players
getting money for anything that happens
on a football field well yeah i mean hey
the steelers mike tomlin are you know
are rooney the second they're they're
gonna be careful of course you know
because yeah this isn't is against the
rules in the nfl but i mean here's the
here's the thing to me first off
this was not anything about a bounty and
that drove me crazy looking at some of
those comments on social media and stuff
over the last you know this past weekend
has nothing to do with that
this is what
at least in my eyes what it looks like
mike tomlin he's a defensive coach
master kwai went over the middle james
harrison hit him with his shoulder
kept his head out of it and i think mike
tomlin went you know what that's
steelers football okay he got fined i
know it's against the rules but i like
his brand of football he tried to hit
him safely and he played physical i'm
gonna help him out he wouldn't be the
first guy in the history of the nfl to
do that he wouldn't even be within the
first thousand of a guy in the nfl that
have done that it goes on all the time
you know if a defensive player has a
play like that where
the team looks at it and goes man i mean
damn you know
he didn't try to hurt anybody it wasn't
what they're looking like oh helmet the
helmet you tried to knock the guy's head
off just good physical play over the
middle i've seen whole defenses come up
for a guy and chip in money for fines
coaches other players play the whole
fine for that player whatever it may be
so it's a very common thing within the
nfl culture and mike tomlin is a
stand-up human being he's not putting
bounties on anybody but if he wants if
you think he doesn't want his team to
play physical pittsburgh steeler type
football
that's a different thing and i think
that's maybe what he was promoting there
more than anything and just kind of
trying to help out one of his leaders of
his football team with that
yeah and look we talked about friday on
friday the the context here
the nfl was still getting its arms
around what was going to be expected of
the sport in this era of sensitivity to
player health and safety it was october
of 2009
that roger goodell and demora smith were
called up to capitol hill for a
subcommittee hearing on the failures of
the league in the union do enough
when it comes to concussions it was
october of 2010 when it was the harrison
hit on muhammad massaqui it was brandon
merryweather on todd heap and it was
dante robinson onto sean jackson boom
boom boom in 15 minutes of real time
that turned the nfl on its head it
encouraged the nfl if not forced the nfl
to be more aggressive in throwing flags
for helmet to helmet hits on defenseless
players
that was kind of the sea change moment
but the thing is the steelers were
standing there saying no these are clean
hits tomlin said no what james harrison
did was clean art rooney at the time
said it was a clean hit so it's easy to
justify this notion that hey uh our guys
are getting screwed by the league office
and right and so
and so we're going to give them some
money back and it doesn't surprise me
that it happened i believe it happened
and chris the next year
ryan clark the former steelers safety i
think he also played for washington he's
with espn now
he was fined 40 000 for an illegal
helmet to help it hit and he said that
mike tomlin used that in slow motion in
the film room to say this is exactly
what i want you to do
so uh it shows there was a disconnect
there and at one point tomlin and rooney
had to go to the league office and meet
with the commissioner because of the
disconnect
between what the league's trying to do
and what the steelers organization was
telling the world is and isn't
acceptable play so
bottom line i believe
that james harrison got an envelope and
i agree with you
it's not a bounty but some would say
chris
that now to the extent that the saints
bounty program was premised on
clean legal hits that incapacitate an
opponent not dirty hits
not you know a jeff gillooly kneecap but
a clean legal hit you go blast that guy
and you put him on the sideline with a
hit that you don't get flagged or fined
for and you get some money
i don't think that that's worse than
paying a guy's fine for an illegal hit
after the fact you could argue it's
worse to pay a guy's fine for an illegal
hit after the fact because if you're
paying is fine and again we don't know
how much money was in that envelope if
you're paying a guys fine you're saying
keep doing it go ahead keep doing it
keep playing football the way you're
playing it even if it doesn't mesh with
the rules the disconnect is the steelers
thought it did mesh with the rules they
disagreed with what the league was doing
that's why that happened at the time
well either way i don't think either one
was about hurting people like you know
with it with without the outside the
scope of the rules i don't think anybody
was looking like for that and greg
williams mike tomlin they're old school
defensive minded coaches and come on
mike tomlin at that time he's the coach
of the steelers they've won super bowls
he's the coach of the steelers because
hey the steelers are famous for their
physical you know blitzburg type defense
and we're going to impose our
physicality and you want to come over
the middle against us you're going to
think twice about it that was part of
football yeah that was not digested at
that point and no i don't think either
one bounty gate or mike thoman are into
hurting people or doing anything illegal
but yeah i mean even to this day if i
saw that hit from james harrison it
would get flagged as defenseless
receiver i get that but i don't sit here
and watch it and i just watched it again
before we started doing this segment to
go oh man that was so egregious and
horrible no he tried to lay a big hit
with his shoulder on a receiver coming
over the middle and i don't think it was
anything to do with like oh my coach
told me he'd do this or oh it's just the
way they're coached in general to be
physical there and i think mike tomlin
was trying to stick up for his guy and
stick up for the culture of what
pittsburgh is on defense
but chris i was talking to somebody
about this last week the steelers have
had a reputation of a team that comes in
hot that comes in with the helmet down i
mean look what happened to ryan shay's
here they come in with the helmet down
i've heard stories about it happening
during pre-season games coaches for
other teams being pissed off about it
about you know they've got that culture
where they come in hot and uh and this
is what happens so um back in the early
days of everyone trying to figure out
what the rules were going to be and how
the nfl was going to be and how it was
going to evolve in light of this
sensitivity concussions uh i could i can
understand why mike tom
screw the league office they're taking
money out of my guy's pocket they're
gonna make my guys less willing to go
out and play the way they need to play
i'm gonna take care of my guy so he
keeps playing
the way that he needs to play
yeah that's exactly it that's what it is
you know i can remember back in the 90s
john montana
paying a neal smith you know wasn't that
neil smith right they used to wear the
band-aid on the kansas city chiefs right
uh i remember he got a fine for
something and telling a story where like
joe montana the next day put an envelope
on his locker damn we should go back and
find the kansas city chiefs we should
they're promoting bad no it's you know
it's just it's a culture of men sticking
up for each other and it's nothing about
being illegal or hurting somebody it's
just a style of football in general
that's what it is and pittsburgh is
famous for that style mike tomlin was
there to be the head coach to make sure
that style continued to get enforced in
his regime in the new era as a head
coach that bill cower had set forth
before him and chuck noll before that
and yes that's the way they played and
they were still adjusting at those times
but you know i don't want anybody to get
confused with thinking that mike tomlin
was set in bounty gate or anything like
that
neil smith the guy who had the great sac
celebration do you remember what a sac
celebration was
what did he do like
he swung the man
he saw the bat that's right that's what
it was i was chopping wood he swung the
bat that's right swung the bat all right
uh that's it for pftot we'll be back
tomorrow with another edition pft live
all day long at profootballtalk.com
when's the next unbutton chris we'll go
tuesday tuesday thursday tuesday i'm not
sure what the hell we're going to hit on
yet thursday i'm not sure what the hell
we're going to hit on yet either but
we'll get there
i'm talking to coach dungy later today
about these enhancements to the rooney
rule you'll see that in the pft pm
podcast we'll see you back here tomorrow
have a great day
you guys see it
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports